so meine lieben bevor es mit dem video
losgeht muss ich noch eine kurze ansage
machen und zwar ist mir leider auf eine
richtig dumme art und weise die face
käme abgepackt in der aufnahme die ihr
gleich sehen werden
deswegen gibt es diese folge mal ohne
face camp tut mir leid dass es jetzt
nicht dazu gekommen ist in der nächsten
folge garantiert wieder mit face kam ich
hoffe ihr seid mir nicht böse und
vergewaltigen ich den dislike button
ganz cool von euch und ansonsten würde
ich sagen wir sehen uns in der nächsten
folge wieder mit facetime vor allen
dingen und jetzt viel spaß mit dem video
s kids und herzlich willkommen zur
zweiten vorstellung ich sage euch heute
das kit
so dass wir wieder und bevor wir mit dem
von uns boxen schauen erst mal die
beschreibung an die beschreibung die
lautet wie folgt der trecker erhält
einen speziellen compass mit dem er bei
dessen benutzung zusätzliche besondere
informationen über den getöteten spieler
erhält und wird von den gegnern gewarnt
auch erhält er eine stadt rüstung das
geld als bisschen schnell ist auch
relativ viel text das heißt also im
klartext heißt das wir kriegen erstmal
rüstung zwei rüstungs punkte leder teile
der spread ladder bild genau wie beim
opfer aber wer jetzt die fähigkeit dass
wir einen besonders krassen kompass
haben dieser kompass zeigt uns natürlich
wieder normale an
wer ist der nächste gegner arbeitszeiten
noch an wie viel leben hat der nächste
gegner und welche klasse hat der nächste
gegner also welches kit das ist ziemlich
cool wenn man einmal so ein bisschen
kalkulieren kann so bohr känguru fünf
herzen vielleicht nicht hier
barbara 10 herzen vielleicht schaffe ich
das noch so und das kitz fast mein
lieblingskind von der neuen liste würde
ich sagen leben auch immer los und schon
was sich zum ergebnis bei
zudem 2011 bekommen es ist immer wichtig
dass man der ersten gäste reisen wollte
solange man kein känguru ist man nämlich
nicht mehr so die optimale chancen
oder hat keine garantie dass man nur
noch aus bekommt aber ihr hört dieses
gebimmel das ist dieser dieses waren
geräusche wasser den den trecker warnt
wenn sich spieler ihm nähern also wenn
spieler nach
ja das kann man sehen wie man will
für manche ist es ein bisschen nervig
ich finde es eigentlich gar nicht
schlimm ist jetzt mal das gleiche bei
euch gerücht wie wenn man jemandem gilt
in der games könnte also sozusagen auch
als über grasser mega tausender
killstreak ausgelegt ja es ist ganz
eigentlich ganz nord- und das geht es
ganz nett
wir probieren zeigt mal aus hier ist der
kompass sacra seht ihr in suppen meister
zog mais hat noch zehn herzen hier und
dann ist der nächste wiederum und
chamäleon der waffenmeister
die suppen weiß der suppe meister machen
meister geht nur empire state meister
fix meister was weiß ich
richtig dicke action hier so wir schauen
jetzt mal die sache ist die dass der
trecker keine pvp fähigkeiten hat
unheimlich schön gegeben das war eine
ganz saubere ganz sauber combo schön
außen herum gelaufen das hat mir gut
gefallen so dass ein geschwächtes
känguru das natürlich auch cool wissen
eigentlich sowieso wieder löwen in der
savanne und seen haid oder können
riechen wenn der feind seien geschwächt
ist ein chamäleon kommen jetzt war für
meister stört chamäleon oder nicht kann
ich habe es keine lust immer ewig her zu
retten macht macht auch irgendwie eine
mehr gute drehung wir sind einfach da
und das auch nicht so boksic auf jeden
fall habt ihr gesehen
man kann so ein bisschen kalkulieren wir
sind zum beispiel davon jetzt barbar und
irgendwie bombe oder so und können so
kalkulieren jahren war ist jetzt nicht
so krass pvp also hat jetzt keine
besonders scheiße gold verloren hat
jetzt keine besonderen fähigkeiten kann
einfach so ja uns denken vielleicht
gehen wir drauf wir schauen mal was wir
sehen nicht aber wir sehen er ist
känguru und hat neun herzen soll das ist
echt ziemlich geil
also ich würde echt sagen dass das
trecker kit fast mein lieblingspferd ist
kündigt vorstellen dass diesmal auch mit
wirklich mal länger spielen war die
anderen geld zu chamäleon oder so
übrigens familien wenn ihr wollt kann
ich euch noch eine vorstellung machen
ab in die kommentare damit chamäleon
finde ich ein bisschen so ganz lustig
oder davon dass ein holzfäller aber halt
nicht so krass jetzt verlässt da oben
na gut da kommen wir nicht hoch aber wir
müssen runter zu werfen wir könnten
jetzt natürlich
wir können den übelsten jolo move machen
einfach ein ende bereiten es
funktioniert wenn ihr an der polizei auf
kommt und dann festlegen
ja es ist passiert
puh das war der richtige ninja action
wurde und es war ein bogen werden bogen
wir sie hat das thema war relativ gut
ist
wir sollten dankbar jetzt aber
eigentlich nicht angreifen
wer jetzt nicht so schlau oder
vielleicht doch weiter kommt noch ein
känguru vielleicht ist das ja den
barbaren dann wenn es lieb ist dass
kängurus oder wir stormy night kölner
haie machen
ich würde sagen mach einfach mal judo
ich habe euch ja schon wissen was
gezeigt von dem kit okay ich will jetzt
einfach drauf gehen aber okay egal am
wasser ernähren wir auch nicht mehr am
ball aber der karambolage ersten tag so
dessen zeuge nehmen wir mit
und wir sehen auch der andere hat nur
noch ein herz sehr geil und daher hätte
hätten jetzt absolut jetzt profit
herausschlagen können dass unser kind
anzeigt wieviel herzen der nächste hat
noch nie habe ich nicht bekommen oder
wie scheiße ist euch durch
ok also viel richtiges gebashe in dieser
runde bleibt stott strategie muss jetzt
aufpassen dass wenn ich der nächste sind
der gelöscht wurde wird wir haben ja bis
jetzt eigentlich ganz gut mitgehalten
manchmal sagen muss man aufpassen damit
klar darum hier so jetzt hab ich keine
reisen längen zu band jetzt auch
erzählen können aber ich habe ich noch
genug zugkraft wer die einfach mal die
bäckerin einen vergessen so ok alles
klar
pam pam das können wieder aufsammeln
haben wir noch gold alter haben folgen
die ja das sehe ich ja jetzt erst wieder
mega viele dias kraft auf jeden fall
guck mal leute wir sehen jetzt hier
rektor visuell p ist bomber und wissen
schon in den letzten 3 ok also ihr seht
mal mit dem mit dem trecker kit kann man
echt ganz gut spielen
gerade wenn wenn zu massenkarambolagen
gibt vanessa wegläuft und sieht man so
bei der hat jetzt der gefeierte der hat
noch ein herz den kann ich jetzt
angreifen
man tendiert zum abstauben was jetzt das
ist vielleicht nicht so trist rest ist
aber man muss es auch so sagen das geht
halt ansonsten keine spezialfähigkeiten
insofern für ich das eigentlich schon
gerechtfertigt wenn man sozusagen damit
jetzt ein bisschen abstaubt ja wenn man
so sagt nennen will finde ich gar nicht
schlimm weil das ist eigentlich alles
das was das kit kann und das finde ich
überhaupt nicht schlimm finde ich cool
es gibt gefällt mir auf jeden fall und
ich würde sagen bis jetzt auf jeden fall
eine klare spiel- empfehlung auf jeden
fall richtig gut bisher gefällt mir echt
gut mal schauen wie sich die weitere
runde entwickelt und wenn sich die runde
jetzt so entwickelt dass vielleicht doch
ein bisschen kürze ist können wir
eventuell noch eine dranhängen
schauen wir mal auf jeden fall cool weil
es erstmal um die sachen hier auch
erzählkino das ist er nicht so gut ging
groß dass man immer schutzlos
ausgeliefert
so jetzt jetzt gucken was man gegen
dieses känguru
wir haben ein wie jetzt nämlich auch die
die negative seite vom vom trecker kit
ist hat keine pvp fähigkeiten
das ist ziemlich scheiße es hat einfach
nur vorbereiten fähigkeiten für pvp dass
man sieht ja wie gut sind die anderen
zumindest was leben und klasse angeht
rüstung wird auch nicht angezeigt
zumindest nicht so weit ich weiß nicht
angezeigt aber es ist halt im kampf wenn
man jetzt mann gegen mann papa da steht
dann ist es nicht das beste was wir
kennen besser aber im gegenzug wissen
kängurus nicht wie viel leben der gegner
den sieg eingreifen wird sagen die
projekte zu stecken schien gerettet
heute trifft uns wird inzwischen fertig
ja aber wir können nicht weglaufen das
bisschen scheiße
schade schade
na gut wie gesagt man kann wenig machen
gegen so ein känguru das hat auch noch
ein bisschen besseres wert als wir es
immer schwierig zu treffen
also auf jeden fall hat jetzt auch schon
mal gesehen welche nachteile das geht
weil man eben keine besonderen pvp
fähigkeiten hat anders als beim mord
farbe meiner die fähigkeiten übernehmen
könnte von einem känguru wenn man jetzt
an zittert man selbst im känguru will
wie gesagt trecker bietet das nicht und
ich sage aber wie lange schon aufnehmen
neun minuten das ist ein ziemlich gerne
länger würde ich sagen
und wie immer geht weil ich das video
gefallen hat last einen like da schreibt
in die kommentare ob ihr euch mehr cat
vorstellung wünscht welches kind ich
vorstellen soll es gibt ja ein paar
andere youtuber die diese kit
vorstellung macht und glaube ich und
vielleicht welche die du nicht gemacht
haben wir bock habt also auf jeden fall
ab in die kommentare damit bietet den
like button wenn es euch gefallen hat
und dann würde ich sagen sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder hart rein was gut
und teuer